did you want to be paying out I mean no
I mean sometimes you think oh you know
what a thought or whatever you know what
would it be like but then I think if you
get if you get it in a negative light
then you don't want it what you do it
again
sure a lot smarter but yeah ten years
after the Hills premiered I flew to
Austin Texas to spend the day with the
guy we know as Justin Bobby what's your
favorite thing to do in Austin play
music and listen to music the former
reality TV bad boy is focused on his
music career with his band Bobby rock we
have a tour coming up in a week
may 17th for the our first US tour yeah
excited we're so excited for the right
reasons
yeah music not for the drama not for
like who's dating they're screwing her
personal life what's going on I don't
have one none I mean stuff that's
probably remain unspoken you know we're
all dark to stay in the light you know
you stay dark are you still cutting hair
yeah yeah yeah absolutely not as much as
the music but I'm a sucker for that
anybody anybody calls any time in there
I need a kite like something comes over
man like yeah
head on over to eat on line comm for
more reveals and updates with the cast
of the hills